(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) O que acontece quando o imóvel não é
arrematado em um leilão judicial?
O leiloeiro vai comunicar ao juiz que não
houve arrematante naquele leilão judicial.
Como é que o leiloeiro faz isso?
O leiloeiro, assim que acaba o leilão, ele
vai fazer um auto de leilão negativo.
Isso é, ele vai colocar nesse auto que
não teve arrematante nem na primeira e nem
na segunda praça e vai protocolar esse auto
no processo específico que determinou que o bem
fosse a leilão.
Pode ser que o juiz determine que o
imóvel seja levado a leilão da mesma forma
como aconteceu o primeiro leilão.
Pode ser que o juiz escolha mudar o
leiloeiro, que ele tire de um leiloeiro menor
para levar para um leiloeiro maior e esse
leiloeiro maior vai ter mais visibilidade para aquele
leilão.
Pode ser que o juiz até mesmo determine
outro percentual de desconto.
Como a gente já falou na aula de
preço vil, o desconto em segunda praça pode
chegar em até 50% do valor do
lado de avaliação.
Mas a gente falou que nada impede que
o juiz, no primeiro momento, fale que aquele
imóvel vá com desconto de segunda praça de
20%, 30%, 40%.
Então vamos supor que o imóvel foi a
leilão com desconto de 30%.
Naquelas condições, não teve nenhum interessado.
Mas se o juiz aumentar aquele desconto, passar
para um desconto de 50%, pode ser que
apareça algum interessado.
Então o juiz tem a possibilidade de determinar
outro leilão nas mesmas condições que aconteceu o
primeiro leilão, mudar o leiloeiro, passar de um
leiloeiro menor para um leiloeiro maior ou até
mesmo aumentar o percentual de desconto que o
bem vai ser oferecido em segunda praça, respeitando
o desconto máximo de 50% que pode
ser aplicado para não caracterizar preço vil.
Existem alguns casos em que o leilão foi
negativo, ou seja, foi um leilão em primeira
praça, em segunda praça, ninguém arrematou.
O leiloeiro vai avisar, então, ao juiz que
não teve arrematação.
Existem alguns casos que vai ser possível que
você, como interessado em arrematar aquele imóvel, você
faça uma proposta para o leiloeiro, para que
o leiloeiro apresente a sua proposta para o
juiz.
O juiz pode, ou não, concordar com aquela
sua proposta.
Vamos aqui a um exemplo.
Você está pesquisando apartamentos para arrematar e escolheu
dois apartamentos que você tem interesse e que
aconteceriam no mesmo dia.
Você só tem dinheiro para arrematar um desses
imóveis, você não consegue arrematar os dois.
Então, um estava inicialmente com desconto de 40
% e o outro inicialmente com desconto de
50%.
Você, como só tem o valor de um
deles, vai ter que escolher entre um dos
dois.
Vamos supor que você escolha o imóvel que
estava com maior desconto, o imóvel que estava
com desconto de 50%.
Então, você voltou o seu foco para esse
imóvel.
Você estipulou o valor máximo que você poderia
oferecer naquele imóvel e no momento do leilão
teve concorrência para aquele imóvel e o valor
do leilão ultrapassou o valor máximo que você
estipulou para aquele imóvel.
Então, você parou de ofertar lances naquele imóvel
justamente porque ele passou o máximo que você
mesmo estabeleceu.
E o outro leilão que estava acontecendo na
mesma hora, no mesmo dia, na mesma hora,
você não conseguiu dar lances exatamente porque você
estava olhando somente para o leilão que inicialmente
era de seu maior interesse.
Quando você vai ver no final, você vai
ver que o leilão que estava com desconto
de 40% não teve nenhum lance, que
aquele leilão foi negativo.
E aí você pensa, nossa, perdi a oportunidade
de pegar um apartamento com desconto de 40
% porque eu quis um de 50%
e o de 50% eu não consegui
arrematar.
O que eu posso fazer para tentar pegar
esse apartamento de 40%?
Você pode perguntar para o leiloeiro que estava
leiloando esse imóvel aqui de 40% se
você pode fazer uma proposta para que ele
apresente ao juiz.
Pode ser que o leiloeiro fale que sim,
que é possível fazer essa proposta.
Pode ser que o leiloeiro fale que não,
que não é possível fazer essa proposta.
Na maioria dos casos, os leiloeiros concordam que
você faça essa proposta e ele mesmo apresente
para o juiz.
Por quê?
Porque o leiloeiro tem interesse que aquele imóvel
seja vendido.
Se aquele imóvel for vendido, ele vai ganhar
o valor da comissão dele.
Então é sempre interessante para ele que seja
vendido.
E pode ser mais interessante que ele espere
a determinação do juiz para um novo leilão
porque ele não sabe se aquele novo leilão
o juiz vai determinar que seja feito com
ele, se vai mudar o leiloeiro.
Ele não sabe quais vão ser as condições.
Muitas vezes o leiloeiro prefere garantir uma venda
do que esperar um futuro que ele não
sabe que vai acontecer.
Então o leiloeiro aceitando que você faça essa
proposta, você vai fazer e ele vai levar
ao juiz.
O juiz pode ou não concordar com aquela
proposta.
Se o juiz concordar, o leiloeiro vai te
comunicar e vai abrir o prazo para que
você faça o pagamento.
O prazo no pagamento de um leilão judicial
é de 24 horas.
Então você tem 24 horas para pagar o
valor da arrematação e o valor da comissão
do leiloeiro.
Se a sua proposta for aceita, você vai
ter as 24 horas para pagar aquele valor.
E aí você vai fazer o pagamento normalmente,
como se você tivesse arrematado no dia do
leilão.
Nada impede que você faça uma proposta por
50% do valor da avaliação.
Veja, inicialmente o juiz tinha concedido 40%.
Ninguém arrematou.
Você pode chegar e fazer uma proposta.
Eu pago 50% por esse bem de
tal forma.
Pode ser que você faça uma proposta à
vista, pode ser que você faça uma proposta
parcelada.
Em qualquer caso, se for à vista, se
for parcelado, o juiz vai concordar.
O juiz concordando, você vai fazer o pagamento
e o imóvel vai ser seu.
Saiba que existe essa possibilidade se o leilão
for negativo.
Entre em contato com o leiloeiro e fale
do seu interesse naquele imóvel se ele pode
ou não levar a sua proposta para o
juiz.